all right welcome back to Malaysia I
don't even abduction whatever
son here and make out cuz he never wants
to make out I don't understand it has a
phase on my butt like he doesn't give it
to me out it I didn't know you know what
it's about but I don't trust you
I'm here with ink she will guide me and
help me
she's like there go there okay we'll go
there I have Ezio and see audio thought
I'd evidence with me - I'm sure it's any
great seats I feel protected I feel safe
let's go - I think I can't remember is
this where it's possible I'm so confused
it's been a while since I played I don't
remember
oh yeah I know where this is of course
of course let's go back once again
before I started this recording I been
walking around for like 10 minutes and
then when I have 20 minutes to record
today and I can't it getting pissed off
about it so I'm sorry if I
who put the DAC your helmet ah told me I
don't trust you
I'm badass I don't wear helmets
[Music]
yes yes yes here it is
finally we can go no I miss the funnel
even though I have ink sets here with me
I need my cell phone I need I want to
make
[Music]
you guys should not
did I die no I didn't do that but come
at me Nia songs okay and we throw the
sheriff and then someone told me if
you're wrong I swear the penis
they're supposed to be of something to
click here this was right how old am I
supposed to find that little thing are
you ante up
[Music]
I saw something
[Music]
look it's a blue classroom
hey I am happy pink is not happy she's
scared
that's it's falling off let's go home
ah ah no not go home Oh penis
[ __ ] he's coming over you can do
something pink
where's the phone I need someone to get
out
[Music]
oh wait I have
all right maybe no
[Music]
but they think he sees me oh oh [ __ ] I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry ha
ha doors everywhere the painting idea
was a bad idea the painting idea was a
bad idea let's get out of here let's
scare me I'll let you go it's sick and
stay
well we got a little class charm what
I don't just I say that - well we have
yes
yes but didn't we pick up a red one you
mean have to redo that part
I don't want to redo it but we've been
in here I want to do something new
[Music]
right now I don't have time
[Music]
yes yes we can go ahead okay
finally if I'm eight I get the feeling
something's ah this is pretty nice
that's on the table yes
yeah oh yeah
well say who's the King go to Castle me
you are not the king of the castle
I am the king of the jack
it's a no problem here
story I don't like sorta just guys story
just our bad news
I told you nope nope nope nope nope nope
Oh the fella in here it's blocked from
the other
let's go no problem I'm scared I'm
running in the darkness
Superman czar without a key but I don't
have a key
are you kidding me are you kidding me
he's kidding me
annoyed kidding me I like it's blocked
on the other side maybe I can use a
crowbar it's different maybe I don't
know it doesn't really make sense but
I'm gonna do
it makes sense it didn't work maybe it's
the dining-hall
thingy like there's good it's been a
while oh really then come what is this
Rick's someone shot bricks here someone
saw the amnesia
anyway
there's got to be something like
yeah I think
like anything they beckon
I don't know what wait what is this hmm
maybe there's another door that was
another door I'm a genius what's this
my father class I bet you my left ball
yes
okay
nothing at all really I don't understand
why they put these rooms that has
nothing in them it's kind of pissing me
off
okay I get that it's storage and they
please Sheraton [ __ ] their behalf of
shares shares I hate you
whoever comes back and sees this mess
he's gonna be like oh no you did him oh
no he did and I'd you stacked chairs I
don't even know what I'm talking about
you have to go back to like the dining
hall
why do they put
don't understand
Oh kidding me
ouch dirt turf it's fired really dirt
maybe I can get water
don't dart me the game just darling
[Music]
come on
[Music]
,
maybe there's a painting jacket
hire me without it
in the storage probably not [ __ ] lame
episode guys I'm sorry I don't even know
what I'm doing
if you have any ideas or anything that
could help me progress in this story
then please go ahead and leave a comment
but if you don't know what you're
talking about that please don't leave a
comment like this
like I don't mind one time you know who
tried to listen this long it's like hey
if you do you miss yeah you have to call
her and I spent like forever trying to
go there and look for it and it was
nothing my controls
yeah okay I'm definitely not fulfilling
oh wait there's a [ __ ] door - holy
crap I'm a genius
this is a chest
I thought Stefano would be I miss the
fondant I have an Co I'm witty what does
this I can do this
[Music]
ah let's go broken lock
maybe this maybe this yes yes yes come
on pull it - the crowbar broken are you
kidding me are you kidding me
but wait with a why I don't know my
crowbar wife how can it break from wood
I can ah I was so happy
Wow maybe I can maybe back in maybe
thank you yes yes yes yes oh yeah how
the heck does that work I don't know but
I'm doing it yes yes I'm doing it yes
yeah
oh nevermind yo this we can't move
what is this this is a yes yes Imogene
now we go here somebody's out of oil
but that's okay
it's in here I don't know but let's go
what is this puzzle puzzle time this is
definitely puzzling so actually it's not
but I'm
this is Josh ah don't say it to me
shovels thud oh no it's devil shovels it
sold our equipment
or the devil show its tongue I can't see
it's so dark
okay so nothing in here
I better look out for this [ __ ] it's so
freaking the arc freaky dfrac I've been
in here
[Music]
No
I am missing
Oh freaking frack oh [ __ ] oh
[Music]
[Music]
man boobs man boobs say why did I do
this after me
I thought it wouldn't see me
oh I get goosebumps and it's you fell
down
that's your why I don't even know
I'm thinking you with me
I wish I could row them
hey buddy I'm a big but if you want to
get out you must I've done this so many
times you should be like hey what's up
my name's piggy sir
sup brah go is go I've been waiting for
you Petey
let's go I'm excited let's go I'm pumped
I'm pumped fist bump
let's go let's go let's go I'm huh let's
go found monster
yay I'm excited he's pretty AMA you're
pretty obnoxious actually how'd you stay
here then sunbae even the cannon yeah
sunbae yeah yeah sweet sweet work my tan
yeah hey yeah let's go find some ladies
PDPA
yeah I think they will be here I saw
some earlier I heard some noise I think
that's a girl yes
all right how long is that for one okay
it's fine - it's cute you
all right it's back already let's go
let's go I'm excited yay do you ever
stop talking
no yay fist bump only winner facepalm
I'm tired I mean it's not talking what I
really have to hand them so now I had it
all right it's cool you can any it's fab
cubed I understand you busy you busy man
P I understand yeah I'll see you
tomorrow man all right
go see you alright see you guys I really
[Music]
yeah
ask me what it feels like seven a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie to say real life I'll be making
good on my promises honesty is pop it
inside of it is listen but I realized I
can't be better than I was later on my
feet cooking up the song when we fire up